on Tick Tock they put up all these
videos these Google employees Facebook
employees Twitter employees of just
their day they're just having a day at
work they're always drinking coffee and
doing these things so here is a Google
product manager Nicole Sai showing what
a day in her life as a Google employee
is and I think you'll understand why
we're showing you this a day in my life
working from the Google LA office I
always grab some candy from the
reception before heading in this used to
be an old aircraft Hangar so the
decorations hanging from the ceiling
kind of looks like an aircraft flying in
before it was a Google office this
aircraft Hangar belonged to Howard
Hughes so there's tons of memorabilia
next I'm gonna pass by these art
installations they're a really good
photo op or you can sit in there and get
some work done I'm gonna head to the
coffee shop to grab some coffee and a
fruit cup since I missed breakfast and
then I'm heading over to this butterfly
themed room to take my first meeting
then I'm gonna head over to the confetti
room to take my next meeting it's so
sparkly and beautiful in here I love
that a lot of our rooms are themed then
I'm gonna grab my two favorite drinks
which is this green tea and coconut
water next I'm going to go upstairs and
grab some lunch they always have pizza
in a variety of different vegetables and
meat the food is always really good and
of course everything you see in the
office is free on my way out of the cafe
I ran into a doogler which is a dog
googler and ran into some ghosts when
they were renovating the office there
were a lot of spooky stories from the
crew so there's a whole area in the
office where you can listen to them then
I got more work done and headed over to
the massage chairs to wrap up my day let
me know what you want to see next as
Connor just pointed out when is this
girl working
did work enter her thought during the
day and as Phoenix said we were watching
this you're 21 right 22. it's joking
you're 22. uh that he said he just said
this was everyone that I went to college
with he wisely dropped out of college
has a great gig over here uh but this
this affect this strange way that they
speak and as he said they all got A's in
high school and then they just go to
these places and then they basically
just become part of the machine but you
see this is one of the things that Elon
was complaining about when he walked in
there why did he fire half the workforce
because first off most of them were
working from home he said that they were
spending literally millions of dollars
on lunch and no one was even eating the
delicious food but you can see they've
created this very fake very uh what
would you call it like plastic world for
these people for these children they are
children who were ill-equipped to do
anything so it is very unclear to me I
don't want to make too much about this
girl at it but it's very unclear to me
whether she ever worked she played with
the dog she checked out Howard hughes's
old memories Amelia she had coffee well
you're not going to believe this one
guys she had to make a video the other
day because yeah he got laid off a day
in my life getting laid off at Google so
I woke up to this really ominous text
from my boss and I honestly had no idea
what it was going to be about so I
called her the minute I woke up and saw
this and she told me to check the news
and my email so I rushed downstairs to
find out that I had lost access to
basically everything I couldn't log into
my email or even check my calendar I
called my boss back and we just sobbed
over the phone because she was also
finding out about my layoff for the
first time today too I started getting
calls from a bunch of my co-workers and
started finding out who else was let go
on my team and some neighboring teams as
well but I think the worst part is that
it seems like no one was consulted on
this decision and everyone was just
finding out about the layoffs at the
same time it just felt like a really bad
game of Russian Roulette and there was
no consistency around who was let go it
was also not Performance Based so it
just felt really random I opened up
LinkedIn which honestly was not great
for my mental health there were so many
people people who were in the same boat
that were both equally as shocked and
blindsided but it did help me feel a
little less alone honestly I spent so
much of the day crying that I just felt
so tired from being sad and wanted to do
something that would just make me feel
better luckily I have an annual pass so
I headed over to Disneyland because I
wanted to go eat my feelings so I
started off with a cinnamon Galaxy
churro and then went to the Teriyaki
Turkey Leg this is a special limited
edition item for the Lunar New Year
celebration at Disney California
Adventure I had some rice krispie a corn
dog did some drawing and even had
another churro I don't really know
what's next for me but I'll be vlogging
my journey and posting more content
about it so feel free to follow along
I really mean this guys this is
genuinely psychotic and again as Phoenix
just pointed out this is a ton of people
like I'm not just taking this random
girl this is what an entire industry has
been created of an entire generation of
young people the weird way she speaks
and who could eat all that the two
churros what else did she have she had
the Spanish Empanada and the whatever no
one could eat that much all right and of
course she does it at Disney like the
whole thing it's just incredible
oh
[Music]
foreign